We're now going to take a look
at another way to visualize
the differences between daily
returns of individual stocks.
Let's get back again to
our daily return chart.
We've got S&P 500 here plotted already.
And let's compare that
to another stock xyz.
Now note here that frequently xyz
moves in the same direction as spy,
but it also sometimes moves a little bit
further like in these sections here.
We'll be able to visualize those
differences in a scatterplot.
So on a scatterplot, there are a number
of individual points or dots.
And each one represents something
that happened on a particular day.
So let's look at this particular day.
On this day, spy was positive,
close to +1.
So we'll look at +1 on spy.
And xyz was about +1 as well but
a little bit larger.
So that day would correspond
to a point about there.
Now we look at each day
one by one individually.
And populate all of our dots
based on what happened each day.
Another interesting day
is this one where spy and
xyz were moving in different directions.
So again we had spy in
positive territory, but
xyz was in negative territory, so that
would represent a dot about like that.
Now if we were to continue this process
for very many days over a long period of
time, for most stocks a trend appears
which is something like this where you
can sort of see there's a relationship
here, maybe a linear relationship.
And, however the dots
are somewhat scattered.
They don't form a perfect line.